[Music]
play much Mass Effect Andromeda but
you're a big nice over public fan so I
want to have you talk about that a lot
and I just wanna talk about our favorite
Bioware RPGs because I feel like I just
was really negative about Mass Effect
Andromeda the more I play it sorry those
first two hours I was negative about but
Bioware has done some fantastic stuff
and this isn't the same studio this is a
new studio Bioware Montreal composed of
like different parts with Bioware the
Canadian parts I'm not I'm not that
familiar with what they've done some
cool stuff past I think we each have
games we can talk about but Cali nice
little Republic I know a lot of people
like this game I love this game but why
do you love this game um oh it's okay so
to start off I think that it hasn't aged
necessarily very well I did I would like
to preface what I'm about to say but I
but I remember first playing it on X the
original Xbox oh my god what year is it
um and I just I liked being able to like
it at the time I had just like gotten
into Star Wars also so I like being able
to explore the extended unit I mean is
it canon I don't even know I'm not super
big into Star Wars as you can probably
tell but I like being able to explore
the universe on my own terms mostly and
I just really liked the structure like
the structure of choice I mean it's
something I hadn't seen in the game
before really that I had played and I've
been looking for something from Bioware
to kind of recapture how that made me
feel and I can't get that from kotor
anymore i downloaded it on my pc and I
was like this game looks horrible I
can't play this any more of the myriad
Star Wars properties I'm video games
this is one of those that people always
say is did the property justice it
absolutely does I actually really
enjoyed the Old Republic the MMO that
they they developed a couple years back
I had to do some guides for it and I
found myself actually just playing it
for fun which I didn't expect at all
yeah I dabbled in it a little bit um but
again and it was just like I was
searching for the coat or feeling and I
just couldn't hit it yeah good god man
on twitch just said this game doesn't
look that much worse than any drama nah
that's not true it looks pretty bad now
but on my Mac like two years ago that
was the most recent playthrough yeah I
mean like it my memory of it is in much
higher fidelity but in action is yeah
it's it's hard to say because it's it's
in retrospect I think that there's a lot
of things it doesn't do very well right
but at the time having the what I felt
was like super open exploration and like
story choice and a story that I found
interesting was all really new to me and
I just want to get that back you go to
did you like it yeah I like to
everything my memory my memory of to is
more hazy actually mmm it's obsidian
though right yeah choose the better one
what do you say John Luke says two is
the better one oh man I thought he said
2001 Republican yeah John Luke's life
you just chime in saying nice doll
Republic 2 is better than the first one
so tweet at him not me to complain Jake
what is your favorite Bioware PG if it's
not nice Dora public what's another one
you like Mass Effect 2 yeah yeah I think
Mass Effect 2 I think especially I mean
John Luke and are actually doing cuz I'm
gonna plug something to we're doing
sadist party on the Citadel which is
basically we're playing Mass Effect 2
and 3 and we're playing in a way where
you kill as many characters as you can
in another reason why I'm so impressed
with Mass Effect 2 is because you I mean
you build up this team and all of them
can die into potentially and just the
way the story changes 3 the way all the
different fact is it takes into account
either it's really ahead of its time and
all the missions are kind of like sort
of little short stories that like it's a
good way to get to know your characters
rather than in drama or you just kind of
like run into them in the world this is
like alright now I need to do a loyalty
mission with this character I don't
particularly like but I want him to
survive and then you get this whole
backstory about why he's why he's
helping Shepherd why he's doing this
you know and it it makes for a really
compelling narrative and I think I think
that is the best Mass Effect game and I
think it is one of the best games I've
played yeah that suicide mission at the
end is just yeah it's incredible the way
they build to it and the way it pans out
and shows you how your choices actually
had consequences you go through the game
is pretty awesome Pete
yo Bioware me I see someone talk about
baldur's gate and they are right all
this gate your gate smaller than mine oh
did you like it no so yeah back in high
school I think it was around 2002 or so
Baldur's Gate 2 maybe its first
expansion came out and that was sort of
my first introduction into like the
Dungeons & Dragons style RPGs and
Bioware's writing that game was very
different as someone who primarily
played consoles even though I had access
to pcs like console games were my thing
but I was really shocked to find like
the visuals though it wasn't like a 3d
game I wasn't trying to do that it was
really great art style really great
writing and depth to the combat system
in character in creation and growth that
I really hadn't experienced before in a
game it's one of those things that I
remember fondly that I would love to
revisit those became those games are
super dense they're really hard
Planescape torment started torment tides
of numenera that just came out recently
it kind of like follows a similar mold
it's not made by Bioware obviously it
has Brian Fargo and in exile
entertainment yeah so that game I don't
know Daniel Starkey a freelance writer
give that review gave it a 9 out of 10
and so I'm kind of enthused to play that
I've heard some other mixed opinions on
the game so I don't know but text heavy
classical RPG very very text heavy yeah
which maybe at the time for me when I
was in high school that was writes be
curious to see how it pans out now but
but yeah like bio rels are older stuff
and then I I went on to play neverwinter
nights as well like the original version
and that game was also pretty cool I
brought all that stuff into a 3d
environment I can't see the name of that
game without hearing in my head torment
tides of marinara
that sounds delicious Italian restaurant
that opened up here in San Francisco
that I opened it what about the guy
screaming anybody mentioned this in the
chat yeah and I'm both sad and dragon
agent excited to talk about know Jade
Empire do you guys ever play Jade Empire
now miss me yeah okay so that's that's
why when I got into Mass Effect
Andromeda I was like I'm looking forward
to these kung-fu yeah I'm looking
forward to the characters and everything
the character in Jade Empire some of my
favorite I wish I knew their names and
like this is one time my memory will
fail me uh I played it once in the
combat got really repetitive because it
was like actual real time combat as
opposed to I mean I guess they're all
real time but you're clicking a it's a
more of an MMO you know you use this
ability and they'll be an animation that
actually attacks them this is you're
actually doing like he's light and heavy
attacks and these combos and you pick a
fighting style like a kung-fu style or
you know you can see this how fantastic
this game look but I I really liked it
I'm amazed that game got made like just
considering the the setting and
everything like that and like the style
and I consider it's a new IP like it it
is really cool there's the dolph ziggler
comment that people say that oh someone
did mention Jade Empire Mike someone did
a power Archangel three three seven one
thank you sorry I missed it uh he did
mention Jade Empire but yeah it's uh it
got repetitive in terms of combat but I
liked it for what it was I like how I
don't know I felt like I actually I took
[ __ ] because I played nice little public
before this and then I played this and
it felt like they took what I loved
about nice little Republic in terms of
characters in the writing and they
actually brought it into this cool like
mythical you know like Japanese
landscape and it was really no no I
really like a lot of characters from it
yeah in I mean kind of like we touched
on earlier even when the combat in these
games gets repetitive it's not really it
didn't it doesn't detract for me as much
as it could in another game because I am
there for the characters and and getting
invested in the story mm-hmm does that
make sense was that your experience with
Jade Empire yeah it was the story the
narrative the character to pull me
through it
was just the combat all throughout I
would have been bored yeah just funny
because it was based on like kung-fu so
someone just said why would you make the
combat in that bad
and kung Fu's Chinese not Japanese yeah
sorry I didn't biting my tongue
you can correctly call me out do it yeah
yes and then yet people are mentioning
Dragon Age who wants to talk about it
Jake do you play Dragon Age I played a
little bit of origins I played
Inquisition did not like Inquisition but
that's all I'm gonna say
Kali do you like any Dragon Age games I
tried I tried Inquisition I played the
first game do you like it I did yeah I
didn't finish it though unfortunately I
was back when I was freelancing
struggling yeah John Luke loves Dragon
Age Origins I think he's dying and
inside you know it's really good I like
Dragon Age Origins I do not I did not
like Inquisition as much I played like
80 hours of Inquisition and I but I
didn't really like it that much I played
for hours that can i made a dwarf he was
my captain first character in origins I
played Dragon Age 2 as well didn't like
it as much but Dragon Age Origins like I
said that was one of the pinnacles of
bio right it's the actual that
overarching narrative was great but
these like Jake you are saying Mass
Effect 2 was good at these little short
stories that you kind of get to know
your characters through I think this
game could did a good job tying those
together an actual good story and of
course you know you can your choices
have consequences in this game as well
but anyway yeah I think Mass Effect
Andromeda is taking a little too much
from Dragon Age Inquisition and how you
explore and I'm not like it feels like
an empty world even though I keep
exploring it I've only been to one
planet that I can talk about but I've
been to more that I can't couldn't that
planet have been a little bit more
exciting yeah very interesting it's
different galaxy why are we yeah why is
just this the same fungal thing we've
seen a lot of sci-fi now alright that is
all the time we have today but yeah we
will have more of Mass Effect Andromeda
coverage up
multiplayer stream today at 2 p.m. like
I said the begin of the show we have
that giveaway evolve is like free games
of gold now so we figured we'd give away
some of those Funko figures they're more
detail but now Funko pop like figures
they're Funko made like action figures
are really cool take the four original
hunters and the Goliath monster are
those the figures you walked up to my
desk and said I have more figures for
your Pikachu collection
they look nothing like that electric rat
but we are giving those away so some few
times in the chat Shiva who runs our
Twitter she posted the link but I just
retweet and go follow gamespot if you
don't on Twitter retweet that sweetie
and then later on the week we might pick
you and you might get those there's five
of them and we'll send them to you and
then there's yeah like I said Mass
Effect Andromeda stream today at 2:00
thanks so much everybody the back
shouldn't leave sucky Eric Tay Richard
Lee like I said we're still decorating
our new set but this is kind of how it's
gonna look from now on so we appreciate
you stopping by as always thanks for the
questions you sent in we will be
covering Mass Effect Andromeda
throughout the week Scott Boras review
will be up on Monday the 20th so you can
come back and see what he thought about
that game after playing the entire thing
oh I just see a change in color someone
has a remote in the back for these
lights
oh I'm sitting on it sorry are you
farting and changing the colors in this
room purple not this room blue make it
blue I like blue reboot colors give it
to me yeah go watch the reboot
it's our jake and i working on the show
we did one on zelda you can go watch
that also Mass Effect Andromeda wrap it
up shut up okay tell me to wrap it up
but we have the story of Mass Effect
coming up now this weekend it's a
documentary series that we've been
working on the UK team and richard lee
and chris beaumont here it went to pax
recently to go talk to the Mass Effect
Andromeda developers about the
behind-the-scenes about starting over
from the original trilogy you can go
watch that that'll be up this weekend
it'll be two episodes
they'll be publishing check it out I've
seen a lot of it it looks great you can
check out more if you want to know more
about behind the scenes of Mass Effect
Andromeda but thanks so much for
stopping by today that is our show we
will be back next week as always 11:00
a.m. Pacific Daylight Savings Time we'll
see you then
[Music]